perhaps the saddest part of the world  being wiped out by nuclear warfare would  be the loss of the WWE no more Royal  Rumbles no more WrestleMania but thanks  to two modders you can bring the magic  of Macho Man Randy Savage to fallout 4  well look at this primadonna PC mater  fancy-pants previously crafted a macho  man mod for skyrim that replaced all  dragons with the wrestling superstar now  he's tag teaming with fellow moderate  aeromax AE to replace deathclaws with  the same champion you can head over to  nexus mods to download the fix for your  pc version of fallout 4 we already know  mods are coming to console versions of  the game at some point in 2016 so here's  hoping macho man makes his way onto our  ps4 and Xbox one in the meantime you can  also download star wars lightsabers for  your pc version the more mods come  around the more crazy content will share  with you on gamespot think of us like  the institute except you know way less  creepy